what's going on guys in this video i'm
going to be breaking down episode 10 of
attack on titan season 4.
among the many reveals that happened
this episode we found out that the
military police want historia to be the
next beast titan
but they've run into a baby sized
problem that changes literally
everything
this video will explain what's going on
with that as well as everything else
that i thought was interesting
including mikasa's true heritage the
full details of zeke's plan
and a subtle throwback to this moment in
season 2. in some parts i'll also
explain the differences between the
anime and manga as there are a couple of
things that caught my attention
in this episode before we get into it
i'd really appreciate if you hit the sub
button if you haven't already
and be sure to drop a like as it does
help out the video
okay so episode 10 was called a sound
argument which was a fitting title
considering just how many important
discussions were had in this episode
it picks up where we left off last week
with man bun aaron telling himself to
fight in the mirror
but this time we get a better angle and
you can see hanji was just standing
there watching him
bizarrely this is not the first time
that hanji has caught aaron talking to
himself inside a prison cell
as back in season 3 she walked in on him
doing the same thing
in that episode hanji began imitating
him and just kept rambling on until
aaron got annoyed
and now four years later history repeats
itself once again
as the commander of the survey corps
hanji came to talk to aaron because she
wants to know why he infiltrated mali by
himself
and by the end of this video i guarantee
you will understand why
if you don't already in this episode we
got a flashback to two years ago
which gave us relevant information that
helps to explain aaron's decision
the flashbacks that we saw in the
previous episode occurred three years
ago in the year 851
and this new flashback happened one year
later in the year 852
during that time difference the port
they were constructing has been
completed
with parodies island now welcoming its
first foreign visitors
for a hundred years in the entire world
there is only one nation that doesn't
completely despise the aldean race
and that is the country of hizaru it's
essentially the equivalent to japan in
the world of attack on titan
as we know it's located in the east
thanks to gabi and the name hizaru
itself
is a phonetic reference to the word
sunrise with real life japan sometimes
being referred to as the land of the
rising sun
two years ago one of their ambassadors
went to visit parody's island
and it was none other than kyomi
azumabito she is the current head of the
azamobito clan
and we've already seen her a couple
times this season with her most notable
appearance being before the declaration
of war
she went backstage to wish willy type of
good luck but after which she left the
area completely
and didn't stick around for his
performance back then we had no idea why
kyomi left
but now it's clear she must have known
aaron was going to attack
given her relationship with parodies
island in the manga
mikasa had a shocked expression at
seeing kyomi for the first time
as her facial features reminded mikasa
of her mother
this scene was taken out of the anime
but it was our first indication that
these two were in some way related
we found out from this random kidnapper
in season 1 that mikasa and her mother
were the last descendants of an asian
clan
that lived on parodies island and that
clan had a special family crest which
had been passed down from generation to
generation
the first time we saw mikasa's mother in
the manga she had just finished branding
mikasa's arm with that symbol
but in that same scene in the anime she
was teaching mikasa how to stitch it
instead
during this flashback we get the reveal
from kiyomi that this is the symbol of
the azamobito clan
and mikasa does actually have the
branding on her wrist in the anime
which i wasn't sure if they were gonna
do that but yeah it's interesting to see
i'm just wondering like have we not seen
mikasa's wrist in the series so far
has it always been covered i can't quite
remember but someone let me know in the
comments
mikas's heritage is significant because
firstly it means that she is related to
kyomi by blood
and it also makes mikasa a pretty
powerful person back in her homeland
around a hundred years ago the ruler of
his rule was a friend of the alien
empire but after the great titan war
the ruler's grandchild was left behind
on parody's island mikasa is the last
remaining descendant of that grandchild
after over a hundred years
which is the reason why kyomi seemed to
get a little bit emotional
anyway moving on i'm going to explain
the details of zeke's plan to save
parodies island
and how we got the nation of his route
to help him with that plan
he knew that the azmobito clan would
want to know that they had a descendant
so he initially got them to meet by
promising he'd reveal that information
this scene in the anime cut out a bunch
of details that were in the manga
so skip to the timestamp on screen if
you just want to hear about the anime
specifically
but for the rest of you i'm going to
talk about a chunk of their conversation
that was left out
in the manga zeke dropped an absolute
bombshell of information
by claiming that he has secretly been an
elding restorationist for his entire
life
the guy who ratted out his parents
massacred the survey corps
and turned the people of ragako into
titans well he was actually on their
side the whole time apparently
zeke's story is that he exposed his
parents because they were soon going to
be discovered by the malian authorities
so by ratting them out he was able to
prove his loyalty to mali and rise up
the ranks
after becoming the beast titan zeke did
all those terrible things because to
restore elder he needed to go along with
marley's plan
marley never knew that zeke had royal
blood so on the surface he pretended to
be a good soldier
who like everyone else was trying to get
the founding titan but
underneath he secretly planned to save
elder by helping to activate the
founding titan's true power
the reason he told kyo me the truth is
because he wanted his route to help with
his plan
and he offered her a financial incentive
to do this that's where the anime picks
up
as he reveals that on parodies island
there is a natural resource
known as the iceberg stone these stones
are converted into gas which powers
their equipment
but they're not the same as the glowing
stones which we saw in the rice chapel
the main point is that the ice burst
stone is a precious fuel source
that can only be found on paris island
and therefore it must be incredibly
valuable
the aliens on the island obviously have
no idea how much it's really worth
so if hizru agreed to help zeke with his
plan then he promised them access to
this resource
zeke offered them a deal they couldn't
refuse as he promised to not only
reunite them with their lost descendant
but more importantly
he promised them wealth that could
restore their nation to its former glory
before we move on it's worth mentioning
that this equipment that zeke gave to
kyomi
used to belong to zacharias when he was
alive zacharias was the second strongest
aldian soldier
only bettered by captain levi but in
season 2
the beast titan threw a freaking horse
at the guy before cornering him on the
ground
the beast titan had never seen odm gear
before so he stole it from zacharias and
now years later
he's using it as a diplomatic gift when
zeke initially uncovered it during this
episode
it was obvious that kyomi was already
aware of what it was despite this being
top secret information within mali
my assumption is that kyomi must have
had a spy working for her in mali
otherwise there's just no way she would
have known of the existence of this gear
anyhow getting back to zeke's plan his
idea to restore elder was to rebuild the
island and turn it into a modern nation
in exchange for parodies giving away
their natural resources the nation of
history would help to establish a modern
army with the latest weapons
and all the other stuff that you might
expect but zeke knows that mali isn't
just gonna leave parodies alone for all
that time
that's where the other part of the plan
comes in as to stop enemy nations from
attacking the island
he needs to meet aaron so they can
perform a partial rumbling with the
titans inside the walls
this partial rumbling will let everyone
know that parodies is not to be messed
with
which will give them sufficient time
hopefully to build up their population
and their army
which will allow them to defend
themselves without needing the rumbling
in the future
for the foreseeable future they will
need to maintain this threat until they
build up their army to a sufficient
standard
so that means that at some point before
their term ends both zeke and aaron will
need to find successes
as we all know to activate the power of
the founding titan you don't just need
the founding titan itself
but you also need a titan of royal blood
and by default that means the only
person who could succeed
zeke is historia historia needs to
inherit the beast item from zeke at some
point
and then spend her remaining years
having as many children as she can
that way the royal bloodline will never
die out and they will always have a
titan with royal blood
and the founding titan hanji questions
the ethics of this plan
because if they go ahead with it then
once historia gets the beast titan
she will have to be eaten within 13
years and then obviously her children
will be eaten by each other just
basically in an endless cycle so um it
is definitely not the most wholesome
plan
and you can see why hanji would have
some concerns about it that said
historia still agrees to inherit the
beast titan if necessary
much to eren's disapproval remember this
flashback happened two years ago
and at this time aaron refused to accept
zeke's plan
not least because he wanted to protect
historia from the fate that i just
described
as time progressed we can see that
present day erin now believes there is
no other way to protect the island
without the help of zeke
which is why he grew so impatient and
went to mali to pick up his brother
the reason aaron was so pissed off with
hanji in the scene i mean obviously
number one he didn't really want to talk
in the first place
but number two he didn't see any other
path for their survival than to go and
get zeke
yet she's acting like she can't
understand why he did it the anime did
this scene
so well and i say that because they
actually added in his titan lightning to
this moment
almost like he was so angry that he was
willing to transform as he stated
he can actually turn into the warmer
titan literally whenever he wants
as his power works even when the user is
trapped underground
as a result his decision to stay inside
this prison cell is a tactical choice
and the cell is not actually restraining
him anyhow
like hanji you might be wondering if
aaron no longer cares about historia
given that he has always been against
the idea of her becoming a titan
while we don't exactly know whether he
is or isn't against historia becoming
the beast titan now
what we do know is that at this moment
it can't happen because she is pregnant
during the episode we saw a conversation
between high-ranking members of the
military police
and they partly explained the situation
as i said these guys are military police
and it was their full intention that if
zeke came to the island
they would immediately turn estoria into
a pure titan
and have her eat the beast titan the
reason they wanted that to happen is
because they don't believe that zeke is
really on their side
and that whatever he's secretly planning
it can be stopped if historia inherits
his titan
according to this guy someone must have
told their plan to queen historia
to stop zeke from getting eaten straight
away his theory was that elena advised
historia to get pregnant
because a pregnancy would mean that she
wouldn't have to eat zeke until after
she gives birth
regardless of historia's motivations if
this theory is true
then her pregnancy has given zeke extra
time to do whatever he's planning to do
whilst this guy was getting drunk on
marley and wine nyle tried to be the
voice of reason
and argued that they can't turn history
into a titan now because it might be
fatal for the baby
although this is his first appearance of
the new season we've seen nile many
times before
as he is the commander of the military
police long-time friend of erwin
and also the guy who argued that aaron
should be executed
the anime then flashes back to one year
before the current events
which was when the scouts were helping
to build a railway system which was
actually foreshadowed in the last
episode
at that time parodies was waiting on
kyoumi to build relationships with other
nations across the world
on their behalf however hanji revealed
that the plan was a failure as the rest
of the world is actually somewhat united
by their hatred of parodies
aaron was concerned that this meant they
had no choice but to rely on zeke's plan
and therefore turn sauria into the beast
titan which as you can see makes him
visibly angry
hanji had one last ditch attempt to
avoid that outcome which is that the
survey core would meet people from other
countries face to face
instead of using kyomi as a middleman
hanji's proposal was that they create a
base in mali
presumably with the help of kyomi and
this would enable the survey corps to
start building international relations
during their conversation on the train
back home the main group then discussed
who should get eren's titan in 5 years
time
with the exception of armin for obvious
reasons everyone had their own arguments
as to why they should be the next
inheritor of the founding titan
but aaron made it crystal clear that he
wanted his friends to live long lives
and therefore he wouldn't allow any of
them to inherit it generally speaking if
you care about someone
you probably don't want them to have a
13-year limit on their lifespan
so erin proved just how much he cared
about these guys when he refused to even
think about them having his titan
in the present day we see most of this
group all in a room together
as they discuss the situation with the
volunteers jon points out that pixies
didn't really have many options than to
do what he did
as no one really knows what zeke is
plotting and the volunteers do
essentially work for him
connie and jon are unsure if aaron is on
their side or zeke side
given that aaron did have conversations
with zeke and marley that only
those two know about as we already know
connie is especially bitter about
sasha's death which is why he's the one
saying they should be prepared to kill
aaron if necessary
in the flashback we saw sasha is one of
the people that aaron said was too
important for him to lose
yet in the present day his actions
willingly put her in danger
that ultimately led to her death
although it's possible like mikasa says
that
aaron trusted them to survive the fact
is that he must have known he was
putting them in danger
but was willing to risk their lives to
eren the prospect of bringing zeke back
to the island
was worth risking the lives of the
people who he said were too important to
give his titan to
so there is a bit of a contradiction
there and jon might be right in saying
that eren has changed a lot
armin didn't really take a side as to
whether aaron is working with them or
against them
but as usual this season his answer is
to talk things out with the man himself
as we saw in the last episode parodies
recently acquired the titan
transformation serum from mali
and if aaron is deemed untrustworthy
which he currently is
then this serum will be used to make
someone else eat aaron
and take away his titans that's why it's
crucial that armin and mikasa talk to
him so they can prove that aaron is on
their side
and save his life from those in the
military who might want to kill him
the episode ends with zeke politely
reading his book whilst the soldiers are
getting drunk
and you can just see from levi's
expression he is waiting for any excuse
to kill this man
with that said that was my breakdown for
episode 10 of attack on titan season 4.
for those who may have missed my
announcement earlier this week my new
discord server is now live
so you just need to hit the link in the
description if you want to join as usual
i'd appreciate if you dropped a like if
you liked this video
and let me know in the comments what you
thought about the episode until the next
one
peace